time testing sites all over the country
are just overwhelmed as more people are
looking to get tested during the
holidays the sites at unlv was closed
last week but it's back open tonight and
they're going to see a lot of folks
that's where we find victoria saha live
with a look at just how many people are
waiting and for how long victoria
hey there denise this site just opened
up about a half an hour ago i just spoke
with someone from the county they say
they already have given out 140 tests
but take a look at this line behind me
cars just backed up i spoke to several
drivers who say they've been waiting for
two hours and that person from the
county told me that they're expecting a
lot more people because traffic around
this area is backed up that they also
called it metro police and university
police as well
the testing site closed from the 19th of
december and just reopened last night
where they tested more than 300 people
compare that to two weeks ago on sunday
the 12th they had less than 200 people
show up this location offers
drive-through testing as well as
vaccinations without an appointment our
team took precautions and spoke to those
waiting laney braithopt was one of the
first in line after holiday gatherings
she and her husband both wanted to get
tested i was like no we just let's just
go early we gotta think about the people
who may not be able to you know
sustain this
you just want to make sure everybody's
okay this is not the only location for
testing nevada health response has
posted clinics labs and pharmacies
offering testing as well as where to
order the popular at-home kits
this site is open sunday through
thursday 5 30 to 10 30 p.m and parents i
do want to tell you although this
location offers vaccines they do not
have pediatric doses here reporting from
unlv victoria saha live local now